hello guys I'm Greg hello I Anita from
the Anita stargazer Channel right yeah
yeah that's what it is type it in - safe
Anita you get off the Keanu Reeves right
who I ever and I get off the judd apatow
oh my goodness there's this wonderful
bit on one of my favorite shows The
Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon called
kids stand up we're kids right stand up
and celebrities perform this Saturday
that's really cute today's specials
Keanu Reeves in jeddah this is the kind
of material we was right oh yeah a
little more suction
yeah ladies and gentlemen welcome
welcome to The Tonight Show
kids stand up every joke you hear
tonight was written by actual kids aged
5 to 10 now please welcome your first
comedian now move the cow let's get him
life really really on
[Music]
[Applause]
okay thank you been here some time and
wondering how do you make a mousse float
to scoop of ice cream root beer and one
move let's see what else is going on
really oh oh yeah knock knock
Abraham Lincoln
why do you know what the president what
is OB pepper do get jalapeno business
good good great I remember these jokes
yeah you got a woman Oh ladies ladies
the horse is really funny stuff back
it's gonna be big now ladies and gents
your next comedian mr. Jamal
[Music]
he's ready man Jimmy action this is that
Lipton bummer we can personating good
what did the world will astronaut say
today guys I mean I've been on the moon
porcupines
porcupine what does the porcupine say
when they kiss
ouch how's that working for you ok ok
give me the light here had one more
knock now - no thanks I prefer almonds
yeah you got another forgot the - thank
you very much agree visit me for touch
me outside
I know you're here yeah me too
my laser helmet I have a real treat for
you making your stand-up comedy debut
with us tonight please welcome mr. Keanu
[Applause]
Reeves principina here
hey guys I got a question for this cake
to make an octopus laughing that's good
on my mind lately what kind of pants
does Mario wear get him get him get him
well my time is almost up
rap [ __ ]' when I leave your mess this is
why can't you hear a pterodactyl go to
the bathroom come on man because it's P
is silent ha ha
[Music]
mama did all of tonight's comedians back
on stage for one last you guys ready yes
why did the Koala fall out of the tree
because it was dead why did a second
qualify of the tree it was hit by the
first koala why did the third koala fall
out of the tree
it just wanted to fit you oh my god I
was adorable dude jokes are so cute and
like the way they all came out with
their own like kind of personality
gimmick it really awesome I like that
but delivery of that was cool I noticed
as I've seen several Keanu Reeves
interviews yeah whenever he talks he
uses a lot of his hair very violent you
never see him talk like that in his
movies but he's oh oh yeah yeah he does
have big hands
Jinjin episode was doing like his uh
Jerry Seinfeld impression I loved like
though man yeah Adam Kent Jimmy Fallon
does like the washed-up comedian like
okay drag never going to be yeah like I
feel like I've seen this kind of weather
yeah then Keanu just comes out with all
that energy I like to submit my most
reoccurring joke I have ever made on
this channel to the Tonight Show that my
father told me at a Hometown Buffet when
I was about my pocket yes when some of
the best jokes of all comments that made
how did Captain Hook guy how you watch
his ass with the wrong hand what what I
call good comedy that's right
okay I got much longer joke okay oh yeah
all right all right I'm going to move
I'm gonna take my time with this one
longer joke here take your time man
there's a guy who work at the morgue
called Stephen Stephen worked at the
morgue and what his job was to do was to
clean up a dead bodies
right job to clean up the dead body rest
job the rough job in one day
let's lack the participation you're
gonna just nod your head and stuff right
here interrupting my material here my
dad told me same day I heard the kappa
no joke no reaction - so what he did was
one day's cleanup a body there was a
corkscrew in this guy's [ __ ] and then
he's like well this is odd so he took
the corkscrew out and then he hears you
are my sunshine my only sunshine a puts
the course drew back in and means it
goes away he takes it out again you are
my sunshine my only sunshine I just
remember the punch line and I think it's
so funny yeah [ __ ] you too soldier I'm
not allowed to know I really put the
quarterback in and he's like freaky now
he's like I don't know what to do right
now so he called up his boss it's like
3:00 in the morning he goes boss twit
wakes up grumpy annoyed he's like what
do you want Steven 3:00 in the morning
like bah sorry to bother you but you got
to hear this he puts the phone up
against the guy's butthole takes out the
course through the box here's over the
phone you are my sunshine my only
sunshine click to go screw back in and
then Steven talk to his boss and his
boss goes you woke me up at 3:00 in the
morning so I could hear some [ __ ]
sing you are my sunshine
today's county people you can subscribe
to our rejected grind we just made a
stargazer go to her channel yeah sure a
lot of great jokes like the ones you
heard - do not even one well no they're
all there today and go check it out
check it out
oh and I want to give a shout out to
person whose birthday it is birthdays
are a birthday shout out see guys I pay
attention to some common look at that
was this YouTube is this person named
Deez Nuts he's his brother his name cold
cold birthday cold the fan of the
channel okay cold you are the [ __ ] in
the
joke you are my sunshine happy birthday
happy birthday coal my job has dedicated
a urinal to Europe